,
MIKE.
WE WILL BE FOLLOWING IT TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALSO HERE TONIGHT IS LOUISIANA
SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY, A MEMBER
OF THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
SENATOR, I ALWAYS APPRECIATE
YOUR VOICE.
YOU SEEM LIKE A STRAIGHT
SHOOTER, ALWAYS TELLING IT LIKE
IT IS.
WHAT IS THE REPUBLICANS RESPONSE
TO WHAT IS HAPPENING IN AMERICA?
BECAUSE IT IS BIPARTISAN.
WHEN YOU HAVE YOUR COLLEAGUE,
SENATOR TIM SCOTT SAYING HIS
EXPERIENCE, I'M WORRIED THAT
AMERICA'S CITIES WILL BURN IF
REPUBLICANS DON'T SHOW UP TO
THIS BATTLE, SO WHAT IS THE
RESPONSE?
>> WELL, LAWRENCE, HERE'S MY
RESPONSE.
I LISTENED TO YOUR MONOLOGUE.
I THOUGHT IT WAS VERY THOUGHTFUL
AND THOUGHT-PROVOKING.
HERE'S MY PERSPECTIVE.
UNLIKE SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES, I
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT AMERICA IS A
RACIST NATION.
WE ARE NOT PERFECT, BUT I THINK
WE ARE GOOD.
NOW, WE HAVE RACISTS IN OUR
COUNTRY, JUST LIKE EVERYPLACE
ELSE.
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN OUR
COUNTRY -- THERE ARE PEOPLE ALL
OVER THE WORLD, LAWRENCE, THAT
ARE GOING TO JUDGE YOU AND NOT
LIKE YOU BECAUSE OF THE COLOR OF
YOUR SKIN.
AND THERE ARE OTHERS WHO ARE
GOING TO JUDGE ME, THINK THEY
KNOW EVERYTHING THEY NEED TO
KNOW ABOUT ME, BECAUSE OF THE
COLOR OF MY SKIN, BUT I DON'T
THINK THAT'S MOST AMERICANS.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S MOST
COPS IN AMERICA.
WITHOUT ORDER, THERE IS NO
JUSTICE.
WE CAN'T HAVE A SOCIETY WITHOUT
ORDER, AND WE HAVE DECIDED TO
HIRE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
TO MAINTAIN ORDER.
WE HIRE WHITES, BLACKS, BROWNS,
MEN, WOMEN, TO MAINTAIN ORDER.
MANY OF OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES ARE A MAJORITY
MINORITY.
AND IF YOU DECIDE, JUST LIKE YOU
WANT TO JUDGE SOMEONE SOLELY BY
THE COLOR OF THE SKIN, IF YOU
WANT TO MAKE A PEJORATIVE
JUDGMENT ABOUT A COP, I'LL PUT
IT THIS WAY, IF YOU HATE COPS
JUST BECAUSE THEY ARE COPS, YOU
DON'T KNOW A THING ABOUT THEM,
THE NEXT TIME YOU GET IN
TROUBLE, CALL A CRACKHEAD.
NOW, HAVING SAID THAT, WHAT WE
ARE REALLY TALKING ABOUT HERE,
WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT HERE
IS THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
CRIME AND RACE.
LET'S JUST CUT TO THE CHASE.
IT IS A STATISTICAL FACT THAT
JUST AS IT IS THE CASE THAT MORE
MEN THAN WOMEN COMMIT CRIMES,
JUST AS IT IS A STATISTICAL FACT
THAT MORE YOUNGER PEOPLE THAN
OLDER PEOPLE COMMIT CRIMES, WE
HAVE RACIAL MINORITIES AND
ETHNIC GROUPS IN AMERICA THAT
HAVE HIGHER CRIME RATES.
WHY?
POVERTY.
BUT THAT DOESN'T TELL YOU
ANYTHING.
HOW DO WE STOP POVERTY?
I DON'T KNOW A SINGLE PERSON WHO
IS POOR WHO WANTS TO BE POOR.
>> Lawrence: THE PROBLEM,
SENATOR, WE HAVE TO GET TO THE
ROOT CAUSES OF CRIME.
BUT EVEN IF -- I LOVE WHEN YOU
SAY LAW AND ORDER BECAUSE IT IS
TRUE.
A NATION WITHOUT LAW AND
ORDER --
BUT EVEN WITHIN THAT LAW, THERE
IS DUE PROCESS.
DUE PROCESS FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
COMMIT THOSE CRIMES, AND DUE
PROCESS FOR THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS THAT HAVE TO CONFRONT
THOSE --
>> WELL, THAT'S TRUE.
>> Lawrence: IT IS ONE THING
TO CONFRONT THE CRIME, WHICH WE
HAVE TO DO AS AMERICANS.
AND SUPPORT THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS THAT DO THAT.
BUT WHEN YOU SHOW UP TO THE
SCENE OF A CRIME AND THE
CITIZENS OF THIS COUNTRY HAVE
GIVEN YOU THAT RESPONSIBILITY,
AND YOU HAVE A BAD SHOOT, THERE
HAS TO BE A PROCESS -- WHICH WE
HAVE A LEGAL PROCESS, BUT
REPUBLICANS HAVE NOT RESPONDED
TO THAT.
>> RESPOND --
>> Lawrence: IT CAN'T JUST BE
"THERE IS CRIME IN AMERICA."
CRIME IS ALWAYS GOING TO EXIST,
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH AT.
>> I CAN GIVE YOU TWO THINGS WE
CAN DO TO REDUCE THE CRIME RATE
AMONG ALL DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS,
BUT ESPECIALLY AMONG
AFRICAN-AMERICAN YOUTHS.
NUMBER ONE, WE ARE SENDING
2 MILLION OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE TE
FAILURE FACTORIES.
LET ME TELL YOU, IF I WORKING
FOR A DAY, HERE IS WHAT I WOULD
DO.
I WOULD TURN TO ALL OF THE
PARENTS OF OUR KIDS BELOW A
CERTAIN SOCIAL ECONOMIC LEVEL,
OF ALL RACES, AND I'D SAY "HERE
IS THE MONEY THAT THE STATE IS
PUTTING UP TO PAY FOR THE SCHOOL
YOU ARE GOING TO.
I'M GIVING YOU THE MONEY, NOT
THE SCHOOL.
USE IT ANYWHERE YOU WANT TO.
YOU WANT TO GO TO A CHARTER
SCHOOL, GO.
YOU WANT TO GO TO A PRIVATE
SCHOOL, HERE'S THE MONEY."
WE HAVE TO HAVE MORE FREEDOM OF
CHOICE AND MORE COMPETITION IN
EDUCATION.
NUMBER TWO, FAMILY FORMATION.
NOBODY WANTS TO TALK ABOUT IT.
I'M NOT SAYING A SINGLE PARENT
CAN'T BE A GOOD MOM OR DAD, BUT
A CHILD WHO GROWS UP IN A
SINGLE-PARENT FAMILY IS SIX
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO GROW UP IN
POVERTY AND A CHILD THAT GROWS
UP IN A TWO PARENT FAMILY.
AND THAT IS JUST A FACT.
>> Lawrence: YOU KNOW,
SENATOR, I HAVE BEEN VOCAL, I
HAVE BEEN FIGHTING FOR SCHOOL
CHOICE MY ENTIRE CAREER.
AND SO I SUPPORT YOU ON THAT,
BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
REPUBLICANS FORM A RESPONSE.
TIM SCOTT HAD A BILL, BUT THAT
IS A FEDERAL BILL.
I WANT TO SEE SOMETHING ON THE
LOCAL LEVEL, AND I WILL INVITE